jordan montgomery jordan montgomery gets
his start today as you said he's pitched
quite well against the tampa bay rays
this year probably the best yankee
pitcher
against them this season
on the ground that's going to go through
the hole between short and third
room serena goes to second base on the
single by franco
line to left field gallow on the run
dives and makes the play
gallows saved an extra base hit probably
a couple of runs we saw joey gala lay
out last night and make a nice catch but
this one's even better so now two outs
with two men on and here's brandon lau
he shoots this one into right a liner
that's gone
into the front row a line drive home run
his 37th of the year and the rays break
out in front
swing and a miss
zunino down on strikes but
not a great start
for montgomery
for the tampa bay rays here this
afternoon it's going to be right-hander
shane boss making his third start
and a swing and a miss on the fast ball
away runaway rizzo a lefty-hitter at 2
47 21 homer 60 rbs via payoff
there goes the right it is high hood as
far good as god
second deck oh rizzo rakes to right
field a homers to cut the deficit to 3-1
2-2
he got him up and away with 98.
gallo down on strikes two strikeouts in
the inning a run on the home run
3-1 raise
it's gonna be something in hard swing
and a miss
along with the four seen fastball
in a cutting the miz he strikes out
sanchez
on three pitches
that's a liner and that's gonna be in
there base hit
cut off by gallo and he's gonna hold
franco to his
second hit a single
two-two
swing and a miss
got him on the curve
that'll send up brandon loud line drive
three run homer to right his first time
and he's got the identical situation now
line drive to right same one as before
judge turns and looks it's another three
run homer he's got a pair of them today
six runs batted in and it's six one
raised in the third inning my goodness
now here's anino with a blast to left
and that one is going to get out the
raves with back to back home runs from
lao and zanino
oh strike three called on the inside
corner
and a fly ball back into right field
with some carry
rosarina with a little leap and he makes
the catch in front of that wall out
there to retire the side
that's a liner gonna head to the corner
one hop and off the wall
and gallo
had a little problem there
almost lost his footing as that ball
came off the wall and he came up with it
on the double by a rosarina
and the pitch hit on the ground to third
o'shella second one on the first it's a
double play
now the yankees get out of trouble on a
5-4-3 double play
here's a 2-2
and it's grounded into the shortstop
area so it's a base in how do you like
that
there's urshella
the o2
punched out right field it's a base hit
it's going to go into the corner gallow
around second he'll go to third or
shella is going to second the ball is
bottled in the corner here comes gallow
he will score going to third is ashelah
and it's 7-2 rays
fly ball deep center field going back
gardner reaches up to make the play and
take an extra base hit away from margot
one two three go the raise we're halfway
through seven two
and that's a cut and a miss
and give judge a chance judge flirted
with home run number 40.
[Applause]
that's a nice stop at third by diaz and
the skipped throw to first picked up by
mejia to retired judge and the yankees
nicely done down there by the ray's
third baseman
and he chases that pitch
one down
you can never have too many runs against
this team and in this building
[Applause]
that's lined into left that's going to
drop for a base head it's an rbi single
by wander franco and the raised lead is
eight to two
and a cut in the miz 97 by him
and he blows him away with 98 right
there
brandon lau got the race started in a
big way with a three-run home run in the
first and then another one in the third
inning wow 2-2
and he lifts this one into right field
that ball's got a chance to go gone home
run the third of the day for brandon
loud and loud becomes the latest rave
with a three-homer game menino at second
margaux at first there's still nobody
out here in the seventh
now here comes swinging a fly ball under
right field heading back judge back to
the warning track to the wall and then
what is gone a three-run homer for
austin meadows and the route is on
12-2 rays
see if they can turn two there's one on
the first it's a double play
boy do they need that
strike three cruz down looking four runs
in the top of the seventh inning
right back to rodriguez let's see if
they turn it into two there's one
and there's two
as velasquez almost cut in front of
labor but a 1-4-3 double play
to end the inning
now ground ball third
down to second one and lao turns the
double play
started by diaz to end this one
it's a 5-4-3 and how
appropriate in the middle of that double
play was brandon lau who led the charge
today